chief White House correspondent John
Robb bosses off tonight live from the
North Lawn good even John brick good
evening to you in the face of continued
economic uncertainty the White House is
considering more bold moves including
possibly taking an equity stake in large
corporations possibly covering revenues
for small businesses and on the health
front today there were more bold moves
as well president Trump today called in
the cavalry directing the military to
send a hospital ship comfort to New York
Harbor the Mercy to a location on the
west coast and he today signed the
defense production act to possibly ramp
up inventories of desperately needed
medical supplies the thing like this has
never been requested and we need
respirators we need ventilators is a big
thing because it's a complex piece of
equipment so we have a lot of
ventilators but we're going to be
ordering more president Trump said at
this point he was only authorizing the
act earlier Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer urged him to use it and use it
now we know that in two weeks the number
of ventilators might become a massive
problem we must get ahead of it and get
ahead of it now the bill is passed as
the Senate moved to pass the House bill
on testing paid leave and unemployment
insurance the Treasury secretary today
said the next phase of fiscal stimulus
could top one point three trillion
dollars the Treasury Department will be
sending out checks in two tranches worth
250 billion apiece the first on April
6th the second on May 18th the size of
the individual checks still unknown
hasn't been determined yet but it will
shortly be determined and people want to
go big as oppose everybody seems to want
to go big the president's saying America
is not a wartime footing yeah I look at
it I view it as a in a sense of wartime
president I mean that's what we're
fighting I mean it's a it's a it's a
very tough situation year new data out
of France in Italy today shows a
troubling increase in serious illness
among younger people who were assumed to
have a natural resistance to the virus
and could even carry it without symptoms
there may be disproportional a number of
infections among that group
and so even if it's a rare occurrence it
may be seen more frequently in that
group and be evident now dr. deborah
birx also alerting Americans to prepare
for a spike in the infection numbers in
the US but only because a backlog of
tests will now be run through a
high-speed system we will see the number
of people diagnosed dramatically
increase over the next four to five days
several times today President Trump
referred to coronaviruses the Chinese
virus the president made no apologies
insisting he's only talking about where
it came from and denied any racial
overtones to the moniker it's not racist
at all no not at all
it comes from China that's why comes
from China I want to be accurate but as
you know China tried to say at one point
maybe this stuff now that it was caused
by American soldiers that can't happen
it's not gonna happen
not as long as I'm president it comes
from China the White House that they
defended the president on Twitter saying
Spanish flu West Nile virus Ebola and
Zika were all named four places
officials said today they still don't
know of corona virus we'll follow the
typical seasonality pattern of other
similar viruses though they are
encouraged by a tail off of cases in
places like China and South Korea
Brett John Roberts live in the North
Lawn John thanks